hello my name is caleb denby and welcome
back
to game review today we're going to be
looking at a game
between uh ding loren and bai shinshi
in one of the greatest chess games of
all time
according to a list i just googled this
was a game played back in 2017 in the
chinese league
and ding had the black pieces here and
we'll see he came up with some very
very interesting stuff so jumping into
it here we have d4
uh knight of six c4 e6
knight c3 arriving at the nimzo indian
after bishop b4 knight f3 is the
three knights variation and this one uh
if you're a fan of my classes you'll
remember i actually went over
a lot of different variations in this
line uh that was played between
uh karpov and kasparov in their world
championship
uh i guess kasparov with with the white
pieces actually
and they played some really interesting
stuff in this game dingleren
chooses to play the move castles here
which is the third most popular move
in the idea with this move as you're
just waiting a single turn
to commit to anything in the center sort
of keeping your options open to see what
white is going to play
in this game bai shinji chose the move
bishop g5
and ding immediately strikes on the dark
squares with the move c5
now after e3 white is happy because he
got his bishop outside of his pawn chain
but he is going to come under some fire
on these dark squares
c takes d4 immediately by ding loren and
now
generally a lot of people like to take
this back with the pawn and you can get
sort of a normal looking game h6 bishop
h4
and something like queen a5 or even d5
here
is perfectly fine for both sides of
course
instead though we see the move queen
takes d4 and this is a pretty
interesting try
white isn't willing to commit to making
this weakness on the d4 square
instead recapturing with the queen and
allowing black
to yes gain a tempo on this queen but
preserving the structure a little bit
more keeping these king side pawns
nice and compact the move h6
is a good inclusion for ding loren and
it gives his king this flight square if
he ever needs it
it also removes this g5 square from the
bishop and also from the knight
at any later point and we'll see it
actually comes with another idea as well
bishop h4 played in the game and now the
move d5
by dingler n this is of course the
natural break for black you need to
break in the center to give some freedom
to your pieces
and this is the break that if black can
successfully make
then he's kind of solved his opening
problems because width
equals equal amount of space in the
center there's no reason
black should really be worse now if the
immediate c takes d5 were to be played
you can expect
either queen or pawn takes d5 when
this is going to fizzle out fairly
quickly
in this case uh
e takes d5 going for the islani
structured by dean loren would also be
perfectly playable
so rather than take immediately by
shinxi tries to increase the pressure
with the mover of d1
now dingler end goes down a very forcing
and very interesting path
uh in this game and this is a maneuver i
actually love doing
with the black pieces here although it
can be very very
risky so in a lot of regozin structures
which look a lot like this with the
bishop on b4 that add on
the knight on f6 and these center pawns
you can sometimes see the move played in
this game
that move is g5 and the idea here is
black is looking to make use of this
this dark squared bishop by playing the
move knight e4
and really pressuring this guy sitting
here on c3
also look out for the fact that this
bishop on g3 is going to be slightly
misplaced
as well the knight on e4 putting
pressure onto
this bishop as well some ideas of even
h5 in some cases
but for the moment just knight e4 and
then
white plays a very very sensible move
here if you make some normal developing
move like bishop e2
you're sort of asking for it here with a
move like queen f6
already challenging this knight on c3
queen a5 as well
and this pressure is going to become
something that very quickly white will
be unable to handle
so in the game knight d2 by by
bye bye uh and this idea
is to simply remove this knight before
it ever becomes a problem and this
is a great way of playing for bai shin
shi
now ding loren comes up with this nice
move knight c5
not willing to trade off the piece just
yet c5 square is a very active square
for this knight and now after queen c2
the unfortunate news for ding is that he
has to do something now
if he holds off and waits for example
uh let's just make a random waiting move
like a6 you're asking for the move
a3 when all of a sudden your pieces are
stepping on each other's toes with
threats of b4 coming so
for example bishop takes c3 queen c3 b4
is still coming
and it's definitely going to be white
with the advantage here
so black has to do something now and
that something is the move
dinglerand played in this game whenever
you get this kind
of structure uh with either color where
you have an extra d-pawn
the key break you always have to look
for is the move
played in this game that move of course
is d4
this is the move black needs to be
looking at here with the extra d-pawn
playing against this pawn on e3
now this move uh this pawn of course is
untouchable by
white if you ever capture this this
knight springs into action here
and this is just dominating with these
active active knights on the board
so this pawn cannot be captured but the
move played in the game is very very
sensible
knight f3 highlights the fact that this
pawn
is pinned to the queen and prevents the
move d takes c3
uh by you know this pin
uh now dingleren uh being you know a
chess superstar genius
comes up with a killer killer variation
uh so it wouldn't be the chest one of
the greatest chess games of all time if
there wasn't a beautiful queen sacrifice
and so dingleran would very much love to
just throw away his queen for free here
with a move like d take c3
unfortunately this just is not good for
ding
because after c takes b2 the circuit can
actually retreat back to d2
and it's sitting here well defended by
this knight on
f3 and so this would of course just be
straight
losing for black so ding
being chess superstar genius plays the
move e5
here and this move is is pretty deep
right this is
pretty deep stuff by ding loren what is
the points well the point is
black is throwing away this e pawn
throwing it to the wolves
all in an effort to draw this knight
away from the d2 square
and it uh worked like a charm we saw
knight take c5 played in the game
if bishop b5 you could have expected
this knight to take
and then uh something similar probably
doesn't quite work here with the extra
piece traded off
but the move queen f6 would be perfectly
okay for black with this bishop
springing to life on the f5 square
so knight takes instead and this is
falling into dingleren's plan
uh he plays the move now d takes c3
sacrificing the queen
like a maniac rook takes d8 comes on the
board
but not with check allowing black to
play his next move c
takes b2 with check to the king and now
black or black is already very much
threatening to get a very strong
advantage here there's only one move for
white that sort of saves the game
in this position and you can't really
blame by xinji for not finding it
because
these positions are just totally totally
absurd
what needed to be played is actually the
move rook back to d2 anyways
now with this knight being drawn away
from f3 black has time to play the move
rook d8
and sort of regain all of the material
if knight f3
now bishop g4 is removing the defender
you can't really unpin this rook because
then this comes with check
and this comes as well so the move queen
takes b2 would have to be played just
snapping this guy off the board
and now the play might continue with
bishop takes f3
or even a move like knight e4 and at
some point
the material is coming back to black for
example queen takes b4 might be white's
best move already
and now we just have some kind
of a position here where believe it or
not uh black
is actually just down upon now is this
horribly losing for black
probably not after the move bishop takes
f3
for example uh gf3 rook d2
queen d2 bishop d2 king d2 it's probably
just a quality
so excellent queen sacrifice for
equality thankfully
for ding loren though uh bai shin shi
did not find the move rook d2 and
instead
tried to play for perhaps more with the
move king to e2
unfortunately he was playing against i
don't know how many times they can say
it chess superstar genius ding loren
who plays rook takes d8 of course and
now after queen takes b2
we have this position
uh and what a position it is we have a
rook
and a knight in exchange for the queen
here for black
white also is a pawn to the good but of
course
the massive downside for white is
one this king and two these pieces
not yet in the game so your challenge
now as ding loren
is to justify this queen sacrifice and
find the best way to go after
the white king so if you guys at home
want to take a moment and try to figure
out what's going on here
i wish you the absolute best of luck
because you are going to have to be a
chess superstar genius like dingleren to
figure this one out
so ding goes for a very forcing line
here you have to have to have to
get at this king immediately otherwise
you're just going to be down a queen
so what's the best way to do that well
you look for forcing moves here as black
you need to do things with tempo
otherwise as i said give white a couple
moves he'll be very much
out of danger here so the move of course
in the game is knight a4
you challenge this queen as soon as you
possibly can
and get this knight into the c3 square
with check
so queen c2 is saving the queen now
knight c3 comes with
check all right great work everybody
uh now if this king tries to step back
to e1
you're asking for trouble with these
discoveries just for example
94 check king e2 95
bishop b5 rook d2 is an extra piece
for black
so you have to come to the f3 square as
white now if you're watching at home
move of the game see if you can find
ding loren's next move to sort of seal
the deal here
it is the best move there are
technically a couple alternatives
but this is the most clearly winning
move or winning
idea uh there are a couple of different
move orders
you can use but best of luck finding
this move
all right go ahead pause the video now
if you want to try to find it yourself
moving along the move of course
is to get at this king try to checkmate
this king
how do you do that well you need to
guard the g4 square
how do you guard the g4 square well you
put your rook here dummy
guard the g4 square what's wrong with
you didn't you consider rook d4
so of course this is the devastating
idea
uh by dingleran now if you capture this
rook of course knight takes d4 picks up
the queen
if you don't capture the stroke and try
to take this knight for example
bishop g4 is checkmate as is pawn
to g4 here so the only move by white is
h3
and then this is what i meant by there
being a couple of different move orders
now the move h5 renews the threat and
you could have played h5 h3 and then
rook d4 first if you really wanted
but ding he's you know a man that gets
straight to the point
plays rook d4 right away lets him know
he sees it just
let them know rook d4 what a move so
bishop h2 now
tries to give this king a flight square
but g4 is
check king to g3 and now
once again black to move find the only
winning move here
by ding loren if you dare
all right of course the move i mean of
course the move is rook to d2
right the point is you are just
challenging this queen
and believe it or not this queen has no
squares available to it
on this active active diagonal and with
the queen off of the active diagonal
the black minor pieces are springing
into the game
and going to deliver checkmate
if queen takes d2 of course 94 is check
and winning the game
so queen b3 now knight e4 check comes on
the board anyways
king to h4 and now once again try and
find
the the the way to push forward if you
dare of course you start with the check
bishop e7 only one way to go for this
king
up to age five and now the
uh the meanest way to deliver checkmate
by
ding loren the move rook takes f2 was
technically winning
with ideas of coming back to f5 for
example
uh here if hg4 knight f6 is check
king h4 knight g4 is check and this king
is just
sort of getting corralled with this
coming later
but dingler in finds the way to do it
simply king
to g7 why not bring this rook to the h
file
and deliver checkmate why not
so king g7 the killer move bishop f4
means bishop f5
once again going for this business
bishop h6
is a check now and this is how bai shin
shi tried to block off this age file
king h7 though just steps out of the
check
and after queen takes b7 uh dingleran
finally relents and does play the move
rook takes f2
trying to checkmate this guy no regard
for his pieces on the queen side
he doesn't need him uh bishop g5
was by shin shi's choice if you try to
capture a knight
on c6 for example this move is just
checkmate this rook
removing the defender of the g3 square
so
bishop g5 instead now knight g3 of
course is not checkmate
after king h4 so
the move played in the game now rook h-a
just
getting this rook back to the h file
uh sort of as promised with the move
king g7
knight takes f7 was played in the game
now bishop g6
is a czech king g4 and
sorry not not king h4 but rather king
takes g4 and now 95 check was
forcing resignation by by shinxi
of course the line would continue knight
takes e5
bishop f5 check king h5 king g7 check
and mate what a game by
ding loren hopefully you guys enjoyed
this
classic by ding loren uh checkmating
whites
on the side of the board sacrificing the
queen
uh really just what a killer game
binding absolutely eviscerating this
king on h5
thank you so much for joining me on this
episode of game review
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time